we believe that the covered 19 is
representing a global challenge that you
know it's all the countries in the world
Qatar has been one of these countries
which being hit by the virus but you
know since since the beginning when it
started to spread close to the region we
took a lot of steps and measure in order
to make sure that our population are are
safe if you will look at the vitality
rate and patterns has been the lowest
around the world and yesterday His
Highness the Emir was participating at
the conference which was hosted by the
UK prime minister for raising funds for
Gavi and he announced his I announced
the contribution of the state of Qatar
by by 20 million US dollars how much is
the world failed in terms of coming
together to deal with this crisis we
have seen countries around the world
dealing with it on a national level
there hasn't been a gathering of the g20
there hasn't been a gathering of any
large group of nations this is a huge
failure by the world is it not well from
our perspective His Highness has
mentioned and has speech yesterday at
the conference yesterday that countries
are between two choices both of them are
better either closing down and and
making sure that our people are safe and
they our economy will be affected badly
or we open up the country and making
sure that the economy is sustaining and
we're putting the lives of our of our
people at risks both both options might
be right and might be wrong but without
collaboration and exchange of experience
and dialogue we believe that none of we
cannot adopt a model and learn from each
other
is it not inevitable now that the World
Cup in 2023 will have to be delayed
because of coronavirus well first of all
the projects of the World Cup
almost at nine ninety percent completion
right now and we hope by the end of this
year or made of 2021 all the projects
will be completed we believe that
pattern is working very closely and very
strong
with different healthcare organizations
to make sure to deliver healthy and safe
world cup and we believe that it is part
of the cure for the world to be back
together and in a more in a happy manner
and coming here we will be able to
welcome them here in Doha in during the
World Cup World Cup games and we believe
that the entire world needs such an
event for for their emotional treatment
after this global challenge that all of
us will face and we will make sure to
deliver the best ever World Cup with the
healthy and safety and safe environment
have you had to look at changing the
design of any of the stadiums have you
had to look at perhaps the idea of
social distancing in order to keep the
World Cup plans as they are well there
are there is an ongoing exercise on the
organising committee with with different
stakeholders to make sure that all the
health health and safety standards are
applied in all our stadiums so it's
still something ongoing and once it's
it's a clear for all of us I'm sure that
we are going to put it out publicly well
that brings us neatly on to talk about
the blockade which I know is something
that you want to talk about clearly
three years on it is ongoing within your
region you are isolated as a consequence
of this blockade you are not regionally
talking to your partner's on coronavirus
on on many other things that must be a
huge problem this crisis has been
manufactured from the beginning and
unfortunately we still didn't see any
acknowledgement by the blockading state
that this crisis is manufactured and
they are still repeating the same
stereotype what we hope for we hope that
one day everyone realized that there are
more regional and global challenges that
we are facing together that makes us
need to talk to each other
and to support each other and to stand
with each other
covered 19 represented one of the recent
challenges that not our country only
facing but also the the entire the
entire world is facing what is the key
to breaking the blockade Donald Trump
has the American president appears to
have tried a number of times to to
intervene
what's the key well we we appreciate the
efforts of the Emir of Kuwait and they
the United States and president Trump
trying to resolve this issue but until
now they are faced with the stubbornness
of the blockading States we hope that
you know one day they will realize that
all needless and we need we need to come
back to reason and to come back to our
senses and resolve the issue in a
civilized way and Qatar has status
position from the beginning whether
publicly or privately with our allies in
the United States or with our brothers
and neighbors and quit that Qatar is
willing to engage in a serious dialogue
that based on mutual respect and
respecting of the sovereignty and the
international law unfortunately we
didn't see any of the efforts going so
far until now but we hope that the
recent efforts by by both by United
States and by the State of Kuwait well
yield to into something positive
positive for our people one of the
concerns that the the blockading States
had was your relationship with Iran and
I want to talk a bit a bit about that
the Emir of Qatar was in Tehran I think
the day after Qasem Soleimani was
assassinated by the Americans
Qatar appears to be trying to act as a
broker between Iran and the West where
do you see the Iranian situation six
months since the assassination of Qasem
Soleimani let me just set it very clear
Iran is our neighbor whether we agree or
we disagree with them they are a country
that we are going to live with this year
next year and forever
so we need to find a peaceful solution
if there is any conflict between Iran
and the region second when the blockade
started Iran is one of the countries
that stood with Qatar very clearly and
in their airspace for us open their
seaports for us and they supported us
and pattern and the cautery people
highly appreciating such a step in the
time of need you need you need you need
the friends to stand with you and iran
proved that they stood with us and with
the Qatari people when and this despite
the disagreement and policies that we
have with Iran and we have been having
these disagreements for for a long time
I mean in Syria in Iraq in Yemen if you
will look at the policies of total and
the policies of Iran has been totally
different after the killing of Qasem
Soleimani the next day I was there in
Iran I was there and in a scheduled
visit to the foreign minister of Iran
and we wanted to seize the opportunity
to calm down the tension because the
tension who has been fuelled
unfortunately by countries in our region
is is going to to fire the entire region
and the entire region is going to pay
for it and we cannot afford it but we
are still in a very dangerous situation
we want to see a final resolution
between Iran and the United States and
Iran and the other GCC countries and do
you see yourself as a broker a potential
broker between Iran and the United
States we cannot be a broker unless we
are asked by both parties but Iran is
our neighbor and the United States now
our strongest ally if we are asked and
accepted by both parties we will be
willing to help but we are preferring to
work together with other countries who
are like-minded and helping them helping
them in order to de-escalate the
situation and calming down this session
I want to talk about Palestine the
annexation plan that Israel is proposing
but can I first ask you about
Israeli Qatar relations there is for
many months years now there's been a
suggestion that is there is a
rapprochement taking place between
Israel and the Gulf states how do you
see your relationship with the Israelis
well when we saw a window of peace back
in the 90s we were one of the first
countries or even the first country and
the Gulf to take the first step to
or having a relation with Israelis and
we opened the trade mission there
Israeli trade mission here in Doha
but unfortunately the Israeli behavior
showed us a year after year they were
not serious about peace and we hope that
these threats of taking decision of
annexation or not real because we
believe it's going to represent as as as
the last bullet and the peace process
between the Israeli and the Palestinian
and we want them to come back to the
table
and directly engage face-to-face there
is an Arab Peace Initiative on the table
that all the Arab countries are agreeing
to and agreeing to have a normalization
if the Israelis are willing to withdraw
from the occupied territories and having
an independent sovereign state of
Palestine with the capital of Jerusalem
Eastern Jerusalem at the borders of 1967